Зупинити "путінський газопровід".
Найтиражніший таблоїд Німеччини "Більд" вважає це єдиною тотожною відповіддю
на отруєння російського опозиціонера Олексія Навального нервово-паралітичною
речовиною з так званої групи "Новачок".
Окремі політики, насамперед з опозиційної партії Зелених,
давно вимагали згорнути будівництво газопроводу "Північний потік-2",
який має постачати російський газ напряму до Німеччини по дну Балтійського моря,
в обхід України та Польщі.
Нині ж їхні вимоги ще гучніші.
Це було б прекрасним сигналом, якби саме зараз німецький уряд сказав,
що виходить зі спільного проєкту, який робиться за рахунок Латвії, Литви й Польщі.
Це був би крок до єднання Європи, цей газогін її розколює.
Голоси проти "Північного потоку-2" лунають вже навіть у таборі однопартійців канцлерки ФРН Анґели Меркель.
Зокрема, голова комітету Бундестагу із закордонних справ Німеччини Норберт Реттґен
заявив, що "єдина мова, яку розуміє Путін", - це жорстка мова.
За його словами, якщо дозволити добудову "Північного потоку-2" після замаху на Навального
та підтримки диктатора Лукашенка, то "це стане для Володимира Путіна
найбільшим підтвердженням правильності політики, яку він проводить".
Натомість сама канцлерка Анґела Меркель наразі не реагує
на заклики відмовитися від "Північного потоку-2".
Навіть якщо напередодні не приховувала свого обурення,
називаючи замах на Олексія Навального злочином
і вимагаючи від уряду Росії пояснень цього інциденту.
У своїх попередніх заявах канцлерка продовжувала відстоювати
необхідність завершення будівництва газогону.
На її думку, замах на Навального і вбивство колишнього польового командира
чеченських сепаратистів Хангошвілі у берлінському парку Тірґартен
повинні обговорюватися з Москвою поза контекстом будівництва газопроводу.
Гадаю, ми повинні розглядати ці дві теми окремо.
Ми вважаємо, що будівництво "Північного потоку-2" має бути завершене у цьому році.
Це проєкт, в якому беруть участь як російський, так і європейський бізнес.
Багато хто сподівався, що докази умисного отруєння Навального
можуть змінити позицію німецької канцлерки, однак Меркель заявила,
що їй немає чого додати до вже сказаного.
На її думку, країни ЄС мусять сформулювати і дати спільну відповідь на отруєння критика Путіна.
Ця відповідь, за словами Меркель, залежатиме від подальших дій Кремля,
зокрема готовності розслідувати обставини замаху.
За зупинку "газпромівського" проєкту, ймовірно, можуть виступити Польща та країни Балтії.
Щоправда, як відзначають експерти, Берлін зробив багато для того,
аби заспокоїти країни Східної Європи.
Так сама Меркель хоч і визнала, що цей проєкт має і політичну складову,
але, мовляв, саме тому німецький уряд домігся від Кремля гарантій
продовження транзиту російського газу через Україну.
Від зупинки будівництва "Північного потоку-2"
застерігають Берлін бізнес-кола Німеччини та низка політиків і експертів.
Не вірить у ефективність такого кроку, зокрема,
глава Мюнхенської міжнародної конференції з безпеки Вольфґанґ Ішинґер.
Слід, звичайно, мати на увазі, що якщо зараз закреслити цей проєкт ,
то цим ми самі собі нашкодимо.
Тому що до нього залучені німецькі фірми, австрійські фірми, інші західні фірми.
Деякі оглядачі відзначають, що "Північний потік-2" був для Німеччини
вкрай важливим з економічного погляду.
Адже він забезпечив би безперебійні поставки російського газу без посередників,
допоміг би німецькій економіці перейти на альтернативні джерела енергії
у найбільш екологічний спосіб
і перетворив би Німеччину в один з найбільших газових хабів Європи.
Однак переслідував цей проєкт і політичні цілі.
Німеччина мала від самого початку усвідомити, що для Росії - це перш за все геополітичний проєкт
і значно меншою мірою економічний чи фінансовий.
Оскільки для "Газпрому" він особливого економічного сенсу не має.
Тепер, на тлі новин про Навального і вбивство у парку Тірґартен, небажання уряду Німеччини
зупинити будівництво трубопроводу викликає різку критику і нерозуміння.
Як всередині країни, так і за її межами.
Що ж заважає німецьким політикам тепер поставити крапку на "Північному потоці-2"?
Причин кілька. По-перше, економічні інтереси. Але також відіграє роль і правове питання.
А саме: наскільки Німеччина може допустити втручатися у цю справу іншим країнам?
Це питання суверенітету Німеччини. Але і питання політичного престижу Анґели Меркель.
Крім того, вказує Ґергард Манґотт, "Газпром" та інші учасники проєкту
можуть зажадати відшкодування збитків.
Так чи інакше, експерт скептичний щодо завершення будівництва газопроводу ще цього року,
не кажучи вже про можливість його запуску.